ettore scola bonsoir alors je n'ai qu'à
moi vous dire je vous ai tenté mais
voilà merci nous sommes tentés mais je
le disais tout à l'heure à mes amis a
été je pense le film qui m'a le plus
marqué dans ma vie parce que j'ai
compris beaucoup de choses sur la vie en
voyant ce film et je suis très heureux
de vous recevoir
mais évidemment les explications étaient
déjà de lambo c'est ça le film un peu
élevé oui elle m'a aidé à comprendre
beaucoup de choses sur la vie notamment
la compassion voilà alors votre père
était médecin vous ai commencé à faire
la médecine qui après du droit est ce
que c'est parce que les études de droit
et est moins contraignante ou est ce que
c'est parce que j'avais des ambitions
politiques
non car j'étais déjà je travaillais déjà
qu'elle j'étais à l'université a dès
lors la médecine ne permettait pas oui
c'est plus la loi non c'était plus
facile
oui c'était moins contraignant c'est
bien ça alors vous avez une histoire qui
est très célèbre sur vous si vous êtes
très tôt le goût des histoires parce que
votre grand père qui était avec nous et
il vous faisait lire des histoires grisé
pour louis deux heures par jour et il
aimait écouter et il aimait beaucoup
surtout la littérature française de
l'histoire française et donc je lisais à
9 ans des choses qui ne comprenait pas
du tout montesquiou lamartine et
napoléon napoléon rien de sainte hélène
à 9 ans elle est extraordinaire mais
c'était sa passion
mais le système peut vous et restez
fracasse oui et c'est la première fois
que j'ai connu que la casse c'est à
travers la lecture et mon grand-père et
puis ça m'est revenue après jusqu'à 92
avaient fait le voyage du capitaine
fracasse se fracasser le premier que
j'ai vraiment compris quoi dans tous les
we entre les boukakes quand on regarde
votre vie on s'aperçoit qu'effectivement
bon nous on a vu les films moi je vous
connaissais pas votre vie mais c'est
vrai que une journée particulière ce si
beau film avec sophia loren et marcello
mastroianni
vous avez vécu ça vous aviez souriant
j'avais 7 1 le jour où une trêve est
devenu fou et j'étais la surveillance
d'un père s'appelait à l'époque à ces
terrains
c'est de rendre et filets de l'armée
italienne j'étais un fils de la louve
oui vous aviez le petit uniforme et tout
ça vous était aux premières loges
elle comprend alors en 47 vous
travaillez dans un journal qui est un
petit peu comparable au canard enchaîné
elle edouard herriot voilà marc aurèle
en france est donc là vous connaissez
vous rencontrez fellini que les chiffres
et caricaturiste et adjé scarpe l adisq
baby qui après j'ai travaillé avec eux
de grands scénaristes sont eux qui il
était un peu plus grand que moi et ils
m'ont invité à faire un peu le petit
[ __ ] sur le scénario est déjà
scénariste affirmé et il me passait mais
glisser le scénario et j'ajoutais des
lignes de gai gai c'est un peu comme
woody allen ou diana il a commencé comme
vous c'est à dire y faisait des gags
pour des écrits pour alberto sordi pour
un tournoi qu'il signait déjà oui j'ai
ben oui parce que après vous étiez aux
bretons chier les scénarios quand un
scénario était mal fonction des fils de
la seaco là il va l'arranger
et vous dites mon père on était malade
chez votre père était celle énervé de
voir ouais il aurait voulu que je
t'aimais dessin heureusement mon frère
est devenu médecin donc ça l'a un peu
soulagé oui mais mais il est mort il
avait des excusez moi mais il avait déjà
vu des films que vous aviez fait votre
père oui oui nous sommes tant aimés ils
avaient oui alors non non il aurait
préféré alors entre 48 et 52 ou fait
vingt scénarii donc c'est beaucoup et
puis après vous écris vous effet décidé
moi je savais pas ça le fanfaron vous
allez oui fonction d'oeuvre absolu
les monstres aussi oui je la marche sur
rome monsieur j'avais écrit au moins dix
films pour le gaz mans pour dire ici
pour perdre un joli pour 12 rbds et
tracer une fanfare en c1 alors 64 fait
votre première mise en scène donc
parlons femmes avec gassman déjà c'est
lui qui m'a obligé à faire de la mise en
scène c'est sa faute si je fais ce
métier qu'elle je voulais seulement
écrire mais c'est lui qui a dit aux
producteurs je voudrais qu'ils soient a
été rédigée dans le 64 et donc c'est mon
premier film c'est avec lui il a eu
raison parce que quand on regarde nous
sommes tentés mais il ya des idées de
réalisation qui sont pas qu'ils sont des
vraies idées de réalisateur quand par
exemple dans le restaurant tous éteints
et qui sont seulement éclairées avec la
douche comme ça où le plongeant au début
qui qui qui se termine qu'à la fin du
film
c'est des idées de vraiment de domme
d'image c'est pas seulement d'hommes
d'écriture toi tant qu'il a eu raison
gassmann nous aimer je pense que
l'écriture le cf est aussi l'image et et
les images le faux les écrire donc je
pense que soir un seul métier je ne
comprends pas comment on peut diriger un
film sans l'avoir écrit alors bon pas
citer tous vos films parce qu'on a
beaucoup diront les plus les plus
célèbres en 79 film que ça vraiment
révélé en tous les cas ici c'est drame
de la jalousie oui 74 ans n'a parlé nous
sommes tentés mais 75 affreux sale et
méchant film extraordinaire où vous
dites c'est l église qui avait qu'ils
aient toujours heureux les pauvres et
vous vous montrez là kevin se parlent
mais les preuves sont malheureux ils
sont méchants et parce qu'ils sont
pauvres
oui et vous montrer la férocité de la
misère et ça c'est un c'est un grand
grand moment aussi passé des choses qui
n'est pas tellement été dit 77 une
journée particulière on en a parlé
les nouveaux monstres 79 la terrasse
avec le doigt dans une encre et crayon
la nuit de varennes le bal enfin bon
pour y passer là on pourrait passer la
soirée ce qu'on peut dire quand même
ettore scola c'est que c'est toujours
des problèmes de société toujours la
grande histoire officielle et des
petites gens en face quand même ça c'est
un peu ça reste quand même jour dans ces
deux thèmes dominent un taux geôles de
mon cinéma c'est la grande histoire qui
passe sur nos toits sur nos têtes nous
prendrons pas partie aux décisions de
grains en politique mais c'est nous qui
faisons les lillois c'est l'homme que le
gens du commun qui vont à la fin
toujours gagner et on le sait faire de
l'humanité alors vous dites la force du
cinéma italien fut d'avoir le génie de
rire de ce qui aurait pu faire pleurer
le cinéma était bien même le plus grave
celui du néo réalisme inédit au cinéma
français du cinéma populiste de le front
populaire du vivier les racines du
terrorisme italienne d'emilie par
exemple quelqu'un qui est arrivé à faire
rire enfin disons sourire avec quelque
chose d'épouvantable plus épouvantables
et c'est toujours cette tradition
finalement alors vous dites
le rire ci doit être à rire contre
quelque chose sur le rire doit doit
s'engager
il faut un livre qui fait bouger les
choses si on peut pas simplement rire
pour se moquer comme ça il faut que le
rire soit positif ou est positive sinon
le rire avec sympathie de quelque chose
on a deux films la chose
le booster rixe et de deux voiles la vie
l'espoir de changer ouais vous êtes un
humanisme croyez au progrès au programme
dit je suis un mélancolique actif un
pessimiste guy ça vous définit assez
bien et aurions une phrase formidable
mcelhone y voyait le type qui dit j'ai
tellement fin que ça me donne envie de
rire ah oui oui c'est ça résoudrait tous
conviennent d ouais c'est vrai que si
sinon me sign arrêt il y à la nourriture
mais au moins qu'il y ait le rire au
cinéma italien aujourd'hui il n'ya plus
ya plus de fellini il pas une hydre
céline visconti des sica comencini dont
4 alors je pense que aussi l'art la
musique la peinture le cinéma c'est un
peu comme la géographie
il ya des ddv grands
moment de plat et puis il ya des
montagnes mais aussi de la peinture elle
a eu des siècles avec des géants de la
peinture puis non la musique que dans le
19e la musique italienne après non je
pense que c'est pas si grave que ça
c'est pas un optimisme à tous à tout
prix mais je pense que c'est leur barre
il faut être convaincu qu sylla piano la
commande du piano le mène à l'enfer
nature plate la lassitude
la pression s'était pourtant il faut
croire il faut être sincère nous faut
travailler avec amour la vague avec
passion puis les montagnes aussi bien
sinon pas de montagne tous les cas merci
j'étais heureux de vous rencontrer et
j'espère que nos années télé spectateurs
aussi on était heureux de vous voir
merci bref c'est boulot c'est merci et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10
tube abonnez vous il m'était impossible
ou